foreign
[Music]
looking for answers
in 2024
the universe
calls back
[Music]
us your leader
[Applause]
hi can you hear me honey now is a really
bad time okay
bye I love you I love you
[Music]
this is new
whoa please State the name of your
Homeworld uh Earth welcome leader of
Earth
we are the United Advanced species of
the Universe I think there's been a
mistake you're not the leader of Earth
sorry for the mix-up commence memory
wife
me
I am the leader of Earth why is your
voice different uh I've always talked
like this since I was a kid which I'm
obviously not anymore but yes I run the
planet the trial of Earth can proceed
uh-oh until then as you say on Earth
okay bye I love you okay okay
do the talk of the communiverse if Mom
could see me now I know what you mean I
ate my mother at Birth but in moments of
great success I regret it that's a thing
for your species no just a me thing
everyone was shocked
[Music]